stormy Daniels is now trying to force
President Trump to answer questions
under oath the adult film star claims
they had a one-time sexual encounter
back in 2006 her attorney Michael
avenatti filed a motion overnight asking
a federal judge for permission to
question the President of the United
States and his private attorney Michael
Cohen about a nondisclosure agreement
Daniel signed the document ahead of the
2016 election
she received a one hundred and thirty
thousand dollar payment from Michael
Cohen the motion also asks for a jury to
decide if that agreement preventing her
from speaking out is valid Paula Reid is
at the White House with details from the
overnight court filing Paula good
morning good morning
this motion argues that the president
has no protection from a civil lawsuit
filed about something that happened
before he entered the White House in
this new motion avenatti argues that the
agreement his client signed was actually
part of an effort to influence the
election and therefore could have
violated federal law a motion filed by
stormy Daniels attorney Michael avenatti
seeks the deposition of no greater than
two hours with both mr. Trump and his
personal attorney Michael Cohen to
determine if the President had a role in
the 130,000 dollar payment for mr. Cohen
to Daniel's eleven days before the
presidential election and you had sex
with him yes among the questions
avenatti wants to ask the president
whether mr. Trump is David Dennison the
name on the non-disclosure also whether
mr. Trump knew about the hush agreement
and whether he authorized mr. Cohen's
actions Wow any testimony given by the
President or Cohen could also help
determine if any campaign finance laws
were broken was it hush money to stay
silent yes the story was coming out
again the motion alleges Cohen's payment
to silence Daniels was made to quote
help ensure mr. Trump won the 2016
presidential election avenatti says that
would violate the federal election
campaign act for the purpose of
influencing any election for federal
office Rikki Kleeman is a CBS News legal
analyst if you given in
kind contribution that has to be
reported none of this has been reported
anywhere everything about this case is
in the public interest so while the
deposition would take place behind
closed doors the public deserves the
right to know David Schwartz Michael
Cohen's attorney has denied the payment
was related to the election mr. Cohen
paid the hundred thirty thousand dollars
but the reason is to protect business
protect reputation and to protect family
and you cannot speculate that it was to
elect somebody President of the United
States the motion also makes reference
to another famous presidential
deposition avenatti claims the Supreme
Court case of President Bill Clinton
versus Paula Jones established the
Constitution does not offer a sitting
president significant protections from
civil litigation I've just received a
reaction from mr. Cohen's attorneys they
described this motion as quote a
reckless politically motivated charade
it's also important to note that while
this non-disclosure is currently being
contested mr. Cohen's attorneys they
insist that this is still a valid
agreement and then mr. miss Daniels is
bound by it and could potentially be
liable for penalties each time she
speaks about her affair with the
president Gail all right Paula thank you